if i could help
one person
uh
to not self-destruct
and hurt themself
or someone else
by sharing my experiences
then that's why i'm doing this
not really sure why else but uh
you know
yeah i can't help to share your story of
course
i think it's gonna help somebody
somewhere
that's the idea
all right you want to tell me tell me
all about yourself kelvin so my name's
calvin i'm from monmouth county new
jersey
i'm one of five
from the same mother
three different dads
three different divorces
uh so my childhood wasn't necessarily
uh
easy
um
i was raised by three women my mother my
oldest sister and my younger sister
that was really difficult i witnessed
the altercation
that would lead to my parents divorce
and
saw my dad being taken away which was
absolutely
insanely traumatic
growing up my mom had a lot of different
boyfriends
and my friends noticed so i stopped
having friends over at a very early age
and then
when i was 14 i suffered suffered a
traumatic brain injury and my brain is
still permanently scarred and atrophied
um
and then a bunch of tragedies happened
in my hometown which is spring like
heights
new jersey
a lot of my homies just started dying or
killing themselves
uh first was an accident
my homie bb
and uh
i was 14.
so i suffered my traumatic brain injury
and then my homies started dying and i
started self-medicating from the age of
14 till 21
or 22
but high school was insane over seven of
my peers or family members killed
themselves via train
or hanging themselves or shooting
themselves in the face
and i knew every single one of them from
my town
and uh
it's still going on today
but uh
amidst the suicides we just started
self-medicating and a lot of my other
homies
died from
heroin overdoses or other overdoses now
it's fentanyl but
uh
this is all happening in monmouth county
new jersey what is it about that area
that causes us i have no idea
to this day i have no idea what happened
to my town
but
children killed themselves years later
those their parents killed themselves
like
and it's still going on
to this day
like
not from my hometown but the most recent
suicide from a predominant family
in brielle
uh happened just two months ago or three
months ago
i do not know what is going on in
monmouth county
but nothing's been done about all the
suicides
or drug overdoses
nothing's been done
and
like i said we just self-medicated and i
self-medicated to the point of
self-destruction and i wound up
endangering the welfare of a minor
and now i'm a
registered sex offender
after years of self-medicating i hit a
bottom
and i endangered
sorry what did the sex offense happen
well i got blackout drunk i was living
in a home with a single mother of four
i got really drunk one night i came home
uh and my the only
reason i used or the only
places i used in the house except my
apartment were the stairwell to get to
my apartment and the kitchen
and that night i used the stairwell and
i stopped at a bathroom on the second
story that was connected to
this woman's oldest daughter's room
uh
and i must have used the bathroom and
then wound up in her room exposed she
was 12 i was 21
and i admitted to
taking her hand and placing it on my
penis
and that was my bottom
and
i endangered someone else's life a
child's life i endangered my life
and
life hasn't been easier since
but without alcohol i've been able to
achieve a lot
and
it's just been really hard
even before
even before my bottom and endangering
that child's life like life has been
incredibly hard and i feel as though i
am not equipped
or missed something along the way
and i'm just trying to share my story so
maybe someone else in a similar position
who
has no direction
and feels like there's no one there for
them
to ask for help before they hurt
themselves or someone else
and you know
quite frankly i don't care about the
negative repercussions of sharing my
story if any
because i'm just here
if i could help one person
i'm not here for any monetary gain i
don't give a [ __ ] about money
like if i could just help one person
one
to get help
that would be
that's why i'm doing this what do you
think would help
someone else or me anyone what do you
what do you think would be i mean
being honest admitting that you can't
handle
this alone
just be honest
like
i'm an alcoholic and i used to
i used to belong to a fellowship
but
the principle one principle i took away
that i
i will forever
that will forever be with me until my
last breath is being honest
and it's
not easy to do
and ask for help is like the one of the
hardest things i've ever had to do in my
entire life
admit i was wrong admit i could not do
this alone
and ask for help
from anyone
and keep asking for help until someone
helps you
what substances were you using other
than alcohol so from 14
to like 22 i was
i experimented with everything except
heroin
uh
i've done
i've drank alcohol i smoked weed i've
snorted cocaine cocaine is not for me
it puts me to sleep
i've done acid i've done mushrooms i've
done ecstasy
but
i will never do heroin
so many of my homies have died from
heroin
i i mean i've put almost everything down
i've been without alcohol
and any hard drug for almost seven years
now
but
i i still smoke weed
uh
but yeah i mean i've experienced i've
dabbled in almost anything and
everything
uh just to try to numb
my pain or escape myself
what do you think you're trying to
escape from
reality
the reality that i was going through
where all my homies were killing
themselves and my home life was
absolutely atrocious
and i was lying and stealing just
my just escaping whatever i was going
through any myself any anything
any obstacle you felt loved as a kid
i don't
uh
i'm not sure
i feel loved a lot more now
than i
did as a kid i guess
i mean my experience was everyone was
putting themselves before
anyone else
myself included so
loved as a kid
i'm sure i was but i didn't feel it
i i i feel it now i'm almost 30.
you've had jobs i've had multiple jobs
yeah uh
nothing
nothing fancy nothing more than minimum
wage my career path before i got in my
way and chose drugs and alcohol was the
nhl and there was nothing else in my way
and that's something i still mourn
is the loss of my uh
dream yeah my career
and i mean i could blame anyone but
ultimately i made a decision
and i chose drugs and alcohol
did you have friends that did something
with their lives got away and did
something great
yeah i have friends that
i guess
did something with their lives but uh
i keep my circles so small
because
like you know i just
i i can't bear to see anyone else
die that i get close to so
the friends that i do keep in my circle
yeah they've
they've achieved
they've achieved quite a bit
and i mean
i'm not saying i haven't it's just uh
i kind of haven't
but something like like moving to new
york city where there's a lot of
challenges a lot of
opportunities
that isn't
i'm going so
uh i most i never tried to kill myself
until most recently
um
and right now i'm just trying to
uh
get properly diagnosed and medicated and
get into therapy and really try to
work through a lot of the stuff that i'm
still mourning
and grieving about
um
and i don't think that trying to
i don't know
like essentially who i am so i can't
just jump into some profession
that i don't
care about
and i don't know what i care about right
now like my only
my career was hockey until i
just ruined my life so
finding something else that i'm
passionate about is very very difficult
um
you know i've i don't know i've
i really don't know what uh what i'm
doing in a
professional
sense but um
i'm just working on me
what are you afraid of
um failure
because i've already failed myself
multiple
multiple times
and i don't know how many more times i
can
bear to do that
did you have any male
role models in your life
um
i yeah
they were my my older brothers but uh
they're much older than me one just
turned 48
and they got out of the house
when i was still like
a
toddler
uh other than that
not really
as sad as it is
wayne gretzky
but yeah i don't know i mean i've
i'm not really
i i just i could say it over and over if
i just one person if one person sees
this and they are hopeless
and they ask for help because they saw
this video like
that would have made
my world
like personally i i feel as though i'm
really
exceptionally [ __ ] up individual
and i'm trying not to be
and i'm trying to
do good
but sometimes i just don't want to do
anything at all
so i reach out to you
wanting to help others
wanting to help others is noble
i really don't know what else to do
there's i really have
i would really
enjoy
helping someone else
through my pain
and
hopefully prevent them from going
through
any more of their own pain
uh
i don't really know how to do that other
than just
send it
just
you seen a therapist before
yeah i have but uh it was when i was
young and
i got flack for it because they just
told my mother everything that i told
them so i haven't seen one in a very
long time
uh and i have an appointment to see one
on the
[Music]
15th
i think
but it's a lot to unload so
what was your darkest point
your lowest point
my lowest point
i kind of hit it
daily
i just get in my head and
i realize that
without humans without me there is no
problem here
this place would
was perfect
before
and after
um
so i kind of hit my lowest like every
day but
maybe the lowest
i ever really hit was
i just sent text message after text
message to my mother telling her to kill
herself
because
i was in so much pain
and i thought that she wronged me so
deeply
that i thought it would be just if she
was no longer alive
um are you angry at your mom
i'm not
i don't know about angry anymore i
certainly resent her
so i guess that is a form of anger
but i'm not i'm not
enraged
by that individual anymore she's my
she's my mother i love her but
both my parents
in my opinion failed me at conception
um
i mean my mom's on
is getting ssi for post
having to do with postpartum for having
me
like literally for having me
and then a judge gave her custody
of me
and in my opinion that environment may
or may not have helped develop
one
exceptionally [ __ ] up individual
it sounds like depression's part of your
life too oh yeah depression anxiety ptsd
the traumatic brain injury is
something that's
not getting better i have permanent
scarring and atrophy to my front and
left temporal lobe
uh
right here kinda
what's that from
uh i was on a razor scooter without a
helmet and i was doing tricks i was a
very active kid sports extreme sports
skateboarding surfing bmx
whatever so i was trying a razer scooter
i tried to trick
i failed
and i hit the back of my head so hard
that my brain ricocheted within my skull
and hit the front of the inside of my
skull so hard that
uh
permanently scarred and atrophied my
front and left temporal lobe it was
equivalent to a stroke at the age of 14.
and uh
after that is when i started
self-medicating
because of my traumas and then
all the deaths of my homies started
happening and suicides
so it was like i hit my head at a
pivotal moment i'm 14. my brain isn't
even fully developed yet
i permanently scar and bruise it
and then i start self-medicating with
drugs and alcohol
because of all the
stuff that was going on in my life
and then i finally hit my bottom
when i endangered the welfare of that
minor
that child
and that helped me realize i was an
alcoholic and i got really honest with
myself
detrimentally honest uh
because like i said no humans no problem
but i don't feel helpless all the time
like not right now like do you have good
days yeah i have good days um
i recently
i'm bipolar and i recently was
prescribed lithium and that's helped a
lot with my mood swings but uh
is this really just a bipolar story
i don't know rather than blaming modmoth
county
i have no idea
um
it might it might be
[Music]
but i mean nothing was ever done
about the suicides or
the drugs
so
you've been suicidal yeah
how serious has that gotten it's gotten
hospitalization because of almost
attempted
so pretty serious
um
and like this isn't a send-off or
anything like i'm not doing this and
then you know
going to
do anything to myself
i'm genuinely hoping that someone
gets help and asks for help before they
become as [ __ ] up as me but if you
were
giving someone advice who was in a
similar situation what would you tell
them go see a therapist get some
medication
see a medical doctor
and
be persistent
because you're dealing with other human
beings as well
and they may have their own problems so
it's going to suck but you have to be
persistent see a medical doctor
ask questions be willing to accept
a
uh
help
in the form of medication or therapy
or a combination
sometimes i'm able to catch myself
but i didn't for years for years and
years and years and
if you're in a similar situation just
please
please ask for help before
you hurt someone else or yourself
we need you
not to be morbid but you're a wasted
resource if you're not
the best person that you can be are you
taking your own advice
currently yes uh my first
therapist appointment is
coming up uh uh
instead of trying to kill myself i
checked into the hospital you stopped
drinking that's great i stopped
yeah i stopped drinking
uh
that was
a big shift for me
uh
not only did i stop drinking i put
everything down for almost five years
um
no narcotic medication just
ssris and and
uh
mood
stabilizers uh
and i tried a lot of different
medications
um
and you know i hit a really
low low recently but
i'm trying to bounce back
and find out how i can be the best
person i can be
and i don't know how to do that yet
i don't even know where to start really
but
i think therapy and medication and
a regular
relationship with a doctor
is going to help this
my mind so i can start to help myself
and i i mean often i don't take my own
advice often
but i mean
it's gotten me nowhere so
right now yes i am
so you're bipolar or borderline or both
or bipolar depressed
uh do you know about borderline
personality disorder
i've not i'm not
uh i'm familiar with the term i don't
know exactly what it is
i would look into that okay borderline
it's similar to bipolar but
all the suicidal
thoughts tendencies
um kind of the point to that i think
yeah there must be something in the
water up there
i wish i knew
something happened
like
like in a mile by a mile
seven
people in within four years seven
i think only one was 18.
so adolescence like
seven
by train by hanging
it was and then my uncle
shot himself in the face the same week
that we lost
mc
not many people from my town know that
because like i'm not gonna burden them
with telling them like oh yeah
my uncle killed himself the same week as
one of our homies did but
yeah i don't know what happened
a lot went by train
a lot went by train
it was brutal
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you do differently
i wouldn't live
i would not come back here
i would not never absolutely not
i would forego that option living yes
again
i'd rather i call it source or home
wherever we came from and wherever we're
going i i'd rather
go home
or go back to source
so something happened there
do not know what maybe it was me maybe i
happened there i really don't know but
ironically enough most of those people
had bullied me at one point in my life
but
i still cared for them as human beings
so it was brutal to see him go
kelvin what would you what would you say
you've learned from all of this
to realize that
this one life i have
is my opportunity to do the best i can
with it
and blaming no one
blaming anyone else even yourself does
nothing
doesn't progress anyone or yourself
god i just
like when i was growing up in my town
and all those all my homies started to
kill themselves i didn't know where to
go
like who did like
i spoke to my parents about it but like
i didn't
i went to a bottle and a bag like
i'm not really sure if there's like
anything set up to go to but
there's hotlines i know that now you can
call like a hotline
but as selfless as i'm trying to seem
like that i'm going to help someone else
this is helping me a lot as well
i'm not going to like
you know deny that or
not make that known um
do you have anyone you can talk to about
this time yeah of course
i think they're tired of hearing about
it though
certainly tired of hearing about it
sometimes keeping you inside can
make it extra yeah i'm going to tell my
therapist all about it usually
when us heights kids
because this all happened in spring like
heights uh
when us heights kids go to a therapist
they kind of don't really necessarily
believe
them
and then they do their research in the
next visit they that a heights kid goes
in they're like
we had no idea
this doesn't happen
but it did
and i mean
i don't know i've done
a few things i guess uh what are you
proudest of
sorry what what are you proudest of in
your life proudest
um
i guess
mending the relationship with my mother
um
i'm proud to be her son
as opposed to
not
because i didn't always feel that way
it's a wild ride
all right calvin thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you mark i
think it's better for you
can only go up
you